العاصمه نستطيع ان نجلس معها من تبقى منهم
لكي نتفاوت لكن في هذه الظروف انا اظن ان
هنالك خيار اخر غير الحكم العسكري
الخرطوم عدد كما كانت في ابريل او في
ديسمبر عند توقيع الاتفاق الايطالي ديسمبر
العام الماضي حتما سيكون هنالك وضع مختلف
البرهان استبعد اي حوار مع حميدتي وقاده
الدعم السريع واضاف ان الحسمه في موقع
احمدتي كنائب له في مجلس السياده ما زال
مؤشرا
المؤسسي ونسعى في
تخرج بلدنا باي صيغه من السياق الى بر
الامان ليس لدينا قيود ليس لدينا حدود لكن
لدينا ثوابت وطنيه لدينا امور لا يمكن ان
نترايا عنها يجب ان يكون هنالك جيش وطني
واحد وهو رب الموضوع سبب قيامه الدعم
السريع بمهاجمه القوات المسلحه اننا نتحدث
عن ضروره توحيد هذا العسكريه كانت السريع
على الاتفاق سوء النهائي للام السياسي
الذي يقصد المرحله الانتقاليه وقاموا هذا
الهجوم القادم الذي اعتبره قادرا وخيار
وتمرد على الدوله لاننا كنا نثق في وجودهم
كانوا متواجدون معنا في كل مكان في مرافق
الخدمه العسكريه